bang bang
what's up guys lunch money time while
wall street's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
we don't have no lunch money today
because we ain't got no wi-fi
we ain't got no wi-fi but we still
figured out how to do this that's fine
they want to knock out the wi-fi with
the storm
we're still coming to you hot i know you
thought that we forgot that polina was
sleeping in
or maybe i was taking a vacation that's
not how this works
but i'm here don't rest she's got on her
patagonia she's ready to go to the
wilderness if it takes that to get this
to you guys
but here we are on friday lunch money
time don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five they've got
three products you can buy and sell
crypto
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against it as collateral
or you can use my favorite product as an
investor and a user which is that you
can deposit crypto
and a stable coin and you can receive up
to 8.6
apy in an interest bearing account
awesome
awesome product go check it out
blockfy.com
lunch money all right what do we got all
right so two things happened
first our internet went out or internet
second president trump uh issued an
executive order that would
ban tick-tock from doing business with
u.s firms in 45 days
since then tick-tock has threatened
legal action
against the executive order saying that
basically
uh they're shocked by the order claiming
there has been no due process or
adherence to the law
what do you mean you're shocked it's
been all over the national headlines for
weeks you're literally banned in india
what do you mean you're shocked
well you guys been under a rock you've
been sleeping is it that there's no
communication lines to china
you guys can't pay attention yeah did
your wi-fi go out
come on you're shocked you're not
shocked you've been preparing for this
you've literally been running ads you
wouldn't hired a u.s citizen as a ceo to
try to prevent
this from happening you're not shocked
you were expecting okay but there were
no there was no due process how would
you
well it's an executive order there is no
due process that's the beauty of an
executive order stop yelling
oh i'll just say i'll talk lower but
that's the beauty of an executive order
is you it's not beautiful
you you don't need yeah no it is
beautiful literally you don't
president not for here's the deal
whoever is on the other side of the
executive order
well stop stealing stealing
user data and potentially sharing it
with the chinese government
potentially sharing it okay
guess what the us in case everyone is
confused the us and china are at war
we're in an economic war we literally
just had a free speech and democracy
battle
using hong kong as the battlefield right
now we're having it play out in the tech
space china has been at war with the
united states
for decades and america is just waking
up to this now
and not only did we go after tick-tock
right and the way they did it is prevent
transactions so that means
three things one if you are an
advertiser you cannot advertise on tick
tock after this
day period what if you're apple two
if you have them in your app store you
cannot do that so apple and google will
have to remove them from the app store
three is if all of a sudden there's no
app store access even if somebody's
already downloaded tiktok to their phone
they can't get the software updates and
so eventually the the
experience will get so bad that they'll
just stop using the product
so this is an outright ban however you
look at it
but they didn't just do it for tick tock
they also had a second executive order
that went out and they went after 10
cent holdings which is the owner
of wechat not what's up facebook sorry
wechat
wechat now here's what's really
interesting wechat there's people all
over the interview like that's the only
way i communicate with my family in asia
but
whatever and then they usually followed
up with well we just assume that the ccp
is listening
that's the whole point that's why they
don't want people to be able to
spy on american citizens and so people
historically have chosen convenience
over security but the government's not
comfortable with that
and so where we end up is we are going
to continue to see this ratchet up both
in the american side
and on the chinese side and as they
ratchet up more and more and more and
more
i saw something as crazy as what if
china in retaliation comes out and says
we're no longer going to allow the
distribution of american music or movies
on our uh in china
who's going to stop them they can do
that it's just like they stopped
facebook and to twitter and google and
all these other people from coming to
their country
the firewall hey should we have a great
american firewall
no guys look the only things we have
there
are the vitamin c and the wine that's
all you need in life
all right what's next all right so this
is also interesting
twitter is going to begin labeling the
accounts of media outlets affiliated
with the governments of countries
on the un national security council
so the new labels won't apply to all
media outlets only
outlets where the state exercises
control over editorial content
through financial resources direct or
indirect political pressures and or
control
over production and distribution so the
labels will go on the accounts of
china daily russia today sputnik and
other media outlets
but not voice of america in radio free
europe radio liberty
which are funded by the us government or
npr and the bbc
and the post described npr and the bbc
as state financed media organizations
with editorial independence
i thought that was really interesting
everybody's got an angle
they're trying to figure out how to let
people know
nobody's gonna care it is what it is
it's all propaganda
there's no truth it's all propaganda
well maybe maybe
now people are gonna be like oh i'm
getting my news from russia today like
maybe i should diversify my
news intake um although but would they
do that because of the label
maybe is that yeah yeah like because
because it's really hard to see on
facebook and then you end up sharing
fake news
but anyway fun fact voice of america
that's what my
uh during uh communist bulgaria that's
what my dad would
try and hide and try to listen to voice
of america
evo if you're watching shout out
i mean look yes they should absolutely
go ahead and uh
and label stuff but it's always gonna be
a cat and mouse game there's gonna be
new one that pops up they don't know
about whatever
all right what's up all right so uber
just reported second quarter results
including revenue that
beat analysts expectations but declined
by about
29 from 3.17 billion during the same
period
last year it's food delivery is doing
well
ride hailing not so much well total
business revenue is down 30
29 year over year which is not good
obviously people that would be worse
which is
what planet uh just said right there but
the key piece of this
is the food delivery business is now
bigger than the rideshare doubled itself
yeah
now 2x on the food delivery business
the rider business fell off but the
question is
how quickly will the ride sharing part
of the business come back and can the
food delivery side stay
as the leader in the business we don't
know yet that's what it's going to take
some time
to figure out um but i do think that
it's very interesting all of a sudden
you can't say that uber's a ride-sharing
company you'd have to say they're a food
delivery company
it's a bigger business so we'll see what
happens well it's kind of like
how facebook was a you know find my
friend type thing and now it's
well and then flip flip side of the
argument lyft doesn't do food delivery
um so they're just getting smacked right
in the chin with the
writers lyft is doing um car rentals
instead of course but they're all
remember what we talked about they're
gonna have to do geographic expansion to
to continue to uh seek growth they're
already doing that
now they're having to also create more
product lines or revenue lines and
that's what we're watching both of them
do right here all right are you ready
for this
let's see am i gonna be upset a little
bit so
there's uh the aspen institute publisher
report that warns that the united states
may be facing the most severe housing
crisis in history
if conditions do not change with up to
43 percent
of renter households facing eviction
this year that's up to 40 million
americans could be evicted by the end of
this
year well they're definitely not going
to get evicted so this is
dumb because it's going to get no
because the laws are preventing anyone
from being evicted
so that there are specific things around
rent freezes
uh eviction protection like all that
kind of stuff now when those
end yes there could be a lot of people
evicted and likely there will be
unfortunately
but the other piece of this the federal
protections on evictions expired on july
24th
so i learned something today look at
that so
uh those eviction protections are over
now
yes my guess is and i don't know this
for sure but that sounds about the same
time that the
um the federal unemployment uh insurance
like the beef up the additional amount
uh also uh was there
and so if that's true then what i wonder
is because the 24th i think was march
24th
when the stimulus package wasn't
announced or whatever it so is you know
three months whatever it was
um i wonder then if in the new stimulus
package will they reinstate those
eviction
protections oh so we'll see i don't know
for sure but we'll see there
uh but the other piece is like why are
people uh gonna get evicted
it's because they lost their jobs so i
saw a crazy static and i i apologize i
wish i remembered
it was either maine new hampshire or
vermont it was one of those
you know one of those states up there uh
41
of private businesses have gone out of
business wow
41 of private business that's pretty
crazy
but private businesses meaning like any
private business you're like restaurants
and cafes
those are all private businesses i know
but like it doesn't include my private
business
yeah oh it's a private business in the
state right so you can't be registered
in the state
and so when you think about that you're
just like wow that's really bad
um and so if you have a bunch of people
that are losing their businesses that
means you got a bunch of people who are
unemployed
and then if you don't have the beefed up
unemployment insurance then that means
that people don't literally they
literally don't have the money to pay
rent
right they they're choosing between
should i get food or should i buy or
should i pay rent
what are they gonna do of course they're
gonna buy food so
it's just a really bad situation and the
crazy part is that we need we
absolutely need people to come together
in congress in the senate and pass a
stimulus package
we got a bunch of people running around
a bunch of like 70 plus year olds
running around arguing with each other
over how many
trillions of dollars they're gonna give
to folks who cares get it done let's go
that's all i gotta say i like your rants
listen i just spit the facts you spit
them
yeah and you yell them yeah people may
not like it what is the truth
ready the nfl's deadline was 4 pm
eastern on thursday for players to
voluntarily opt out of the season if
they don't want to play them at the
coronavirus pandemic
more than 60 players have informed the
league they intend to
opt out interesting
do they get paid i don't think so oh
oh players who opt out of the season are
paid a 150
000 salary advance my brother wrote
about this my brother should be paid
back
yeah my brother uh joseph um
is he just started a new uh newsletter
and what he's basically writing about is
the money in sports
or the money and business behind sports
and what he was making argument
uh was basically this hundred fifty
thousand dollars if you're a rookie
and you're about to get cut because uh
training camp got cut short
well rather than get cut and get paid
nothing you should just take 150 000
and then uh live to like fight another
day right like
come back to camp next year and so look
a bunch of
these guys are gonna have to make all
kinds of decisions uh the fact that 60
people opted out
is pretty crazy um and i think it was uh
in the nfl one of the guys opted out to
continue to serve as like a hospice
worker
in his hometown and keep fighting corona
that's really
crazy oh i'm gonna cry don't make me cry
okay you're gonna cry no we're good
it's like it's just a touching story
yeah you remember pat tillman
yes yeah they got killed by his own guys
and the army lied about it
fast he made me watch that i cried it's
just the whole thing
see i told you i'm always going to tell
you guys the truth he got killed by his
own
his own guys um all right what else we
got all right i don't know i was
covering i was trying to
not show you but i'm going to show you i
thought it was my joke but it's not
so okay so there's this no drama llama
it's a it's a real live llama look at it
let me show the people
you see this llama and it's being walked
yes
caesar cool caesar the no drama llama is
helping keep the peace and
protest his name is caesar mccool
mccool the no drama llama uh
so he tends to defuse situations and
people enjoy being in his company his
owner told insider
once a champion the animal now works as
a therapy llama an alum activist
how do you say that they combine the
words
so because it ends in an a get it so
caesar is a retired six-year-old grand
champion show llama turned llama
activist
and it's been providing therapy services
in llama
love at the portland protest over the
last few months
hold on it ain't working well you've
seen the videos online they're shooting
tear gas at each other and kidnapping
people off the streets because obviously
the llama
isn't working no but look people are
tweeting like i for one am
all for caesar the no drama llama
turning up at the protest and people are
hugging it
i i like this idea what just so we're
all clear
i don't know about you guys but these
are not the same types of photos that
i've been checking out from uh
the uh the protest in portland okay well
it's helping
look i love the idea i therapy dogs
therapy llamas
whatever you want to do bring everyone
mcdonald's whatever just try to get it
to everyone chill out when larry mccool
i think that's the the
man takes the llama to marches though
he's especially careful about its safety
when
tear gas is going off they get out of
the way oh that that's really smart
what a smart guy well all right anyway
do you like uh i love the llama llama
see caesar mccool yeah hold on let me
find a joke
guys no internet is weird yeah
i had to listen i had to actually talk
to polina today oh it was crazy
i just took a nap i wish no i've been
dealing with all the wi-fi people
okay um what do you call a bear with no
teeth
a bear with no teeth
i don't know a gummy bear
it's like gums it's funny
come on laugh laugh come on yay
i didn't think it was funny but it was
it was like clever all right
it was uh intriguing use of the american
language too
it's not american language it's english
no
i i know but americans have a monopoly
on it
okay italian plaintiff is real now what
i call it american language i think it's
funny
um all right that's it for lunch winning
today while wall street's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right
don't play with the bears don't play
with the llamas just stay inside
stay a no drum alone i'm gonna start
calling you that see you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to eight point six percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends